we're going to do the most amazing Taco
okay a taco a taco taco right and it's
going to be done with shrimp and we're
going to Flay it with some teila and I'd
like you to get your fingers dirty for
once take the knife take the knife and
start chopping this why is your knife
the well because I'm a chef and you're a
cook so so slice the shalot in half okay
and slice this and Sh in half yeah and
start chopping KN it's much harder to
use this knife than that big knife there
you go there you go
okay here you take the little one and
see how you like it all right okay can't
use this one either I'm not really good
nice and fine nice and fine all right
nice and fine next you don't mind a
little finger in there do you little
freckled finger all right well let's
pretend that went well no one really
cares if I do this well a little bit of
sh
okay and then from there take your chili
chili yes chil right here slice off the
end okay I'd like a smaller knife for
this one thank you thank you this so
change my mind I want a big one cut off
the end right there okay slice it in
half all right can you just concentrate
for 2 minutes no I cannot if you have
Ridin on you I'd be glad all right here
we go cut this chop up the chili okay
okay chilot garlic chili okay okay now
from there okay now what take oh Jesus I
i' for I've just forgotten how bad you
are I only make Ramen Pride noodles
that's the only thing I cook okay I
never made anything else right okay
right olive oil into a pan olive oil
into a pan speci oh I like to do that
okay
right now
P okay olive oil in olive oil there
chots GS and chilies into the pan okay
all at once I didn't cut it doesn't
matter we whatever right we're just
going to eat yours we're not going to
eat mine right all at once and that's in
there and that's cooking up little
seasoning okay okay A little touch of
salt okay how much salt do you do little
pinch just a small
pinch oh Jesus salt
pepper right shrimp come on shrimp
shrimp in shrimp in let's get the shrimp
in now give the pan a little toss push
and pull this is where people get hurt
push and pull there you go push away and
pull back to you good man keep her in
the pan nice nice nice
nice right okay this way right from
there a little bit of orange orange okay
over the shrimp these shrimps are
amazing they're from Santa Bara spot
prawns
okay what are we doing here we're just
is the this is the skin this is a little
zest zest the skin of the orange okay
now from there some lemon all
right I do things my way and you do it
your way oh Jesus Christ the say wrong
and you're right see okay you are such a
donkey come on okay right from there
okay A little toss a little toss that's
it good nice nice nice right oh
watch
it okay right from there tequila in
Tequila tequila in how much tequila okay
a nice couple of tablespoons okay and
then little Flom
nice touch more touch more ready
[Applause]
and come
on
you right come on
okay okay watch those those Ginger locks
okay be careful okay now one more final
toss before we go up in Flames there now
blow out the flame carefully it's gone
mine just went
out you know what I did I just looked at
mine and went out Gordon right
tacos okay right from there right here
okay A little bit of creme fresh crem
fresh in each one some tomato little
tomato right there you say tomato I say
tomato the whole segment off there we go
your parsley take your shrimps okay in
the center three shrimps per portion be
generous okay oh look what I got over
here hey yeah yours look like alcoholic
shrimp so sat in there right and then
finally roll them nice and
tightly okay and take a bloody good
bite M that is not very good delicious
give this man